[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic le vide dans le langage courant le
vide désigne l'absence de toute matière
visible on dit par exemple qu'un verre
évident
à partir du moment où il ne contient pas
de liquide en réalité d'un point de vue
fondamental le verre n'est pas
réellement vide
bien au contraire il renferme un nombre
gigantesque de molécules d'air plusieurs
milliers de milliards de milliards qui
forment un gaz invisible à l'oeil nu
mais qui constitue une forme de matière
bel et bien réelle et concrète dans
l'optique de réaliser certains types
d'expériences il peut être intéressant
de s'affranchir de l'air ambiant dont la
présence pourrait être dérangeante pour
ce faire il suffit en quelque sorte de
pomper l'air pour le faire sortir d'un
récipient dans la pratique il est
impossible de créer un vide parfait mais
on peut aujourd'hui s'en approcher
fortement grâce à des techniques
modernes qui permettent de réduire de
plusieurs milliers de milliards de fois
le nombre de particules présentes dans
le récipient
cela dit les vides de laboratoires les
plus extrêmes sont quand même loin
d'être parfaitement vide
il fournit encore de plusieurs milliards
de particules dans chaque mètre cube
si l'on veut trouver un milieu qu'ils
soient encore plus vides que ce que l'on
créé en laboratoire il est nécessaire de
quitter l'atmosphère terrestre pour
voyager dans l'espace
[Musique]
dans l'espace entre les planètes tout
d'abord par exemple au sein de notre
système solaire
les particules sont très rares on en
compte seulement quelques dizaines de
millions par mètre cube mais c'est dans
le milieu intergalactique
c'est à dire entre les galaxies que l'on
trouve le vide le plus parfait avec en
moyenne une seule particule par mètre
cube avec une densité si faible il
faudrait s'intéresser à un volume
capable d'englober notre planète entière
si l'on voulait retrouver le même nombre
de particules que dans un verre vide
dans le vide en l'absence de matières
certaines propriétés qui nous sont
familières cesse d'exister
tout d'abord si l'on essayait de jouer
de la guitare dans le vide
il serait impossible d'entendre quoi que
ce soit carla vibrations des cordes ne
pourrait pas se propager jusqu'à nos
oreilles
plus généralement en l'absence de toute
forme de matière pour pouvoir
communiquer les vibrations
le son ne peut pas se propager dans le
vide ensuite à la surface de la terre
l'atmosphère exerce un poids avec lequel
elle va appuyer sur les objets qu'elle
contient elle exerce ainsi une forces
d'écrasement colossal
cette force équivaut au poids de deux
éléphants adultes pour chaque mètre
carré de surface
c'est ce qu'on appelle la pression
atmosphérique
si on ne la ressent pas au quotidien
c'est parce que notre corps et la
plupart des objets génère également une
pression interne vers l'extérieur qui
s'y opposent parfaitement cependant
imaginons que l'on s'intéresse par
exemple à une bouteille en plastique
dans laquelle on va faire le vide en
pompant l'air qu'elle contient
maintenant qu'elle est vide
la bouteille ne peut plus s'opposer à la
pression extérieure car elle ne contient
plus rien elle va donc se faire comprimé
brutalement par le poids de l'atmosphère
enfin un espace vide n'a pas de
température à proprement parler en effet
on appelle température le degré
d'agitation des particules au sein d'un
milieu dans l'air par exemple il fait
plus chaud lorsque les molécules d'air
sont plus agités et plus froid
lorsqu'elles sont plus calmes dans le
vide en l'absence de particule il est
impossible de mesurer le degré
d'agitation de quoi que ce soit et la
notion de température au sens
d'agitation n'a donc plus aucune valeur
le transport de chaleur ne peut plus se
faire qu'à travers la lumière et les
autres ondes électromagnétiques qui sont
le seul type d'onde avec les ondes
gravitationnelles capable de se propager
dans le vide
[Musique]
imaginons désormais que l'on puisse
s'intéresser au vide non plus à notre
échelle mais à des échelles
microscopique toute la matière qui nous
composent et fait d'atomes un atom
consiste en un noyau autour duquel
orbite des électrons le noyau et près de
cent mille fois plus petit que l'atome
dans son ensemble mais ils monopolisent
à lui tout seul
99,9 pour cent de sa masse totale
le volume d'un atom est donc
principalement vide ce qui signifie en
quelque sorte que toute la matière
visible les composés en majorité de vide
pour conclure même l'espace le plus vite
possible ne sera en réalité jamais
parfaitement vide
en effet selon la physique quantique
le vide est constamment rempli d'une
multitude de particules virtuelles qui
apparaissent et disparaissent en
permanence c'est ce qu'on appelle les
fluctuations du vide
une particule virtuel est une particule
qui existent pendant une durée tellement
courte qu'il nous est absolument
impossible d'observer les lois de la
physique quantique autorise des
particules de ce type à apparaître à
partir de rien à condition qu'elle
disparaisse suffisamment vite afin qu'il
soit impossible de les observer les
particules virtuelles ne pouvons pas
être observés elles ont le droit de
posséder des propriétés étrange qui
défient les lois de la physique
classique comme par exemple le fait
qu'elles apparaissent à partir du vide
ou encore le fait que certaines puissent
posséder une énergie négative
bien qu'il soit impossible à observer
l'existence de ces particules virtuelles
entraîne cependant des phénomènes
concrets et mesurables
d'une part elles sont à la base des
quatre interactions fondamentales de
l'univers
c'est par exemple en s'échangeant des
photons virtuel que deux charges
électriques sont capables d'interagir à
distance d'autre part elles ont
également des effets indirects comme le
fait qu'elle génère une certaine
pression sur les objets ou encore le
fait que les trous noirs puisse
s'évaporer au cours du temps leur
attraction gravitationnelle très forte
permettant de transformer les particules
virtuelles en particules ordinaire c'est
ce qu'on appelle le rayonnement de
hawking
beaucoup de scientifiques pensent
aujourd'hui que l'énergie quantique
contenu par le vide pourrait être une
explication à la nature de l'énergie
sombre
cette fameuse forme d'énergie inconnue
qui tend à aix pendre l'univers de plus
en plus vite
mais lorsque l'on compare son intensité
à celle de l'énergie sombre on trouve
une valeur 100 milliards de 70 décision
deux fois trop grande
c'est l'un des plus grands mystères non
résolus de la science moderne on l'a
baptisé la catastrophe du vide
[Musique]